mac jones in the pro day let's start
with do we want to start with you want
to start with mac jones let's start with
mac jones that's the guy we've been
talking about so much over the course of
the last five days because
some believe many are saying that the
49ers moved up to number three to get
mac jones including the guy with the
insight into the brain of kyle shanahan
christopher david sims calling his shot
that shanny moved up to get mac jones
and it was shanahan present at the mac
jones pro day when he could have gone to
ohio state instead and as shanahan said
monday no reason to be coy at this point
they got their third pick locked in they
know they're gonna get whoever's left
after trevor lawrence and presumably
zach wilson so uh what did you think of
the mac jones pro day second time he
threw but this time
future employers standing there
inspecting
what what uh jones was able to do or not
do i thought it was a better workout
than his first one i think that's where
i would start baseline like he just let
it fly a little bit more he was a little
more aggressive altogether the first
workout i felt like there was a little
bit of the
you know
okay i just want to be accurate and
complete the passes and you know just
kind of check the boxes that way i feel
like this one there was a little bit
more
urgency in his drop and the way he
approached just throwing the ball he
made it a little bit more like
game-like with oh i'm gonna pump here
and then throw here and move in the
pocket and do that type of stuff but
more than anything i just think it was
the throws themselves there definitely
was more
power in his throws you know velocity
the way the ball just the way the ball
spin those type of things some more
aggressive down the field throws than we
saw the first time around again he's not
gonna be the kind of guy that we're
gonna get done with a workout and go
oh wow i'm drooling all over myself this
is the most unbelievable thing i've ever
seen no what he's gonna do is you're
gonna go
damn he doesn't miss throws damn he's
got quick feet damn it's effortless for
him to throw every ball damn he has
every club in the bag you know he's got
the pitching wedge he's got the driver
he's got the six iron he could throw the
ball with any which trajectory he needs
that's the beauty of mac jones it's not
going to be
whoa how explosive is his arm and all
that his arm is plenty explosive it's
it's plenty good but it's not going to
be mahomes or zach wilson or some of the
or even a justin fields as far as the
power in his arm
usually what happens at a pro day
workout it's all scripted it's all
rehearsed it all goes perfectly
except for teddy bridgewater in 2014
when he did his pro day workout and took
his gloves off that was the mistake he
made that's the one pro day workout that
stands out as it was a disaster usually
it all goes well usually it all looks
good usually everything about it we say
wow wow wow wow wow which causes
a moment from yesterday's mac jones
workout to stand out a little bit
because
gabe it gave
kyle shanahan potentially a little
flashback chris here's the the deep
throw from mac jones guy's wide open
he's the only guy out there oh and he
overthrows him by five yards and there's
the
curb your enthusiasm music as kyle
shanahan looks on because
he he remembers
this right now
now different circumstances obviously
higher degree of difficulty than the pro
day workout
i don't know what to make of that moment
you tell me what you make of
mac jones with kyle shanahan john lynch
there watching overthrowing by five
yards the guy who was down the field
with no one covering no rush that that
was hurrying mac jones it was fishing a
barrel he just missed the barrel yeah
that that's it's fine you know again you
could take a lot of the great
quarterbacks in football and they could
go throw post routes like that and
they're gonna miss a few you know
because it's it's you know you're
throwing a ball high in the air at times
it's about oh wait let me time my
you know my drop up with this guy had
did he hit it full speed from the get-go
did he take more of a you know
smooth approach from the get-go and use
build up speed and then get to the
12-yard mark and make a move and then go
explode and do things like that you know
there's a lot of factors that could go
into missing that throw that's nobody's
going to evaluate that and think
anything about it there's no big deal at
all and especially mike the big thing is
too
is when you go back to the film and you
just go wow he doesn't miss these type
of throws you're not going to sit there
and over analyze that type of stuff on
the field if it doesn't really show to
be an issue in real games or anything
like that so i think that's the big
thing and you can watch plenty of mac
jones film and like i've said many times
just the way they called the offense
this year
shows me that they thought he was a
better down the field thrower more
aggressive thrower stronger arm than tua
last year i mean they they were not
afraid to push the ball and i don't
think that'll be a problem with mac
jones and i don't think you know kyle
shanahan or bill belichick or anything
like that is going to think twice about
him missing that post route you know
verse there
i don't want to make excuses for the guy
he missed the throw there was no one out
there he should have hit it but based on
my own limited athletic ability i will
say this the more time you have to think
about something the greater the chance
it's not going to go the way you want it
to when you don't have that luxury to to
really focus and you just have to do it
it's more mechanical
and
agree wide open shot and basketball
versus having a hand in your face
sometimes with a hand in your face you
just do what you have to do when you
have that wide open shot you think oh
boy i better not miss this so uh again
what we saw yesterday and what we see in
any of these pro day workouts you're
never gonna see in a game because number
one they got pads on number two there's
other guys on the field and number three
it's not scripted and rehearsed and
you're not gonna have completely perfect
pro days but uh but but again it's it's
it's look if kyle shanahan
take someone if he's if he was already
planning to take mack jones right and if
he crosses him off
the list because of that throw then you
know he's got to run the risk that the
guy he gets ultimately isn't going to be
as good when it's time to go out and
play the games and uh i i if you're
going to make that decision based on
that one moment that just would seem
kind of odd to me no come on everybody
missed throws i mean you know as much as
i loved zach wilson's workout and gushed
about that there was throws he missed
trevor lawrence you know justin fields
whatever
it's not going to be perfect and you
know again yeah you explained it a
little bit there is sometimes more
pressure
in this type of environment because you
are thinking and you know thinking about
what you've worked on oh let me keep my
shoulder in all right let me keep two
hands on the ball and those type of
things where you're not gonna think
about that during a game you're worried
about wait what did the coach tell me to
read okay wait is that big dude about to
crush me let me move out of the way whoa
he's barely open let me throw the ball
and no point do any of the mechanics
coming to your mind so there is that
aspect and hey also the guy running that
route could have he could have just run
three go routes in a row who knows maybe
he was tired and just didn't hit you
know six gear the same way he had
earlier in the workout again
don't don't over analyze uh it there's
too much good on the film and the
workouts have been really good too
to just go okay what i saw on film uh is
confirmed by these workouts it's a guy
that's really smart incredibly accurate
with the ball a really natural fluid
throwing motion you know with plenty of
power in his arm and what we saw again
yesterday is
he's a better athlete than people want
to give him credit for it's on the move
he makes a throw running to his left and
fading away and throwing a go route down
the left sideline he makes plenty of
throws on the run to go to to go along
with it so uh he's not going to be a
specimen but he's a really damn good
quarterback and can play the position
the right way and has all the tools to
play it the right way at the nfl level
you make a good point too quarterbacks
are conditioned to always take the blame
when there's a moment like that we don't
know whether or not there was right
a failure by the receiver to be where he
should have been and think of it this
way i don't know who it was that was
running that route but you know in a
game setting
maybe you do find the extra gear maybe
you do lay out sure
you're not going to risk an injury at a
pro day workout and screw up less than a
month before draft day wherever you may
end up because you you had to be a hero
to prevent mac jones from having an
overthrow you're just not going to do
that you're not going to screw up your
own interests to make a catch that maybe
you could have made in a game setting
agreed and you know honestly at the end
of the day too
well would you rather him under through
it you know i mean we all know we'd like
him to throw it perfect and hit the guy
in stride but
you know i would also say when the
receiver has to like slow down and catch
the ball
and do that that could
get picked off exactly that could be
that that i think a lot of coaches will
look at that in a lot of ways and go
well that i'd rather him overthrow it
and just let it go let me see what it
looks like wait you know oh wait he's
under throwing a few go routes now and a
few post routes yeah they were caught
but they were on the throne oh is arm
strength a problem you know that's where
that can start now that becomes a
question if you saw that you know
repeatedly throughout a process there
too so uh
again let's not over analyze with this
there was a lot of good in that pro day
and uh mac jones is going to be a real
good nfl quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports